now once we heard the man accused of the
crime was from las vegas we also learned
about where he lived and what he did joe
mohler joining us now live near spring
mountain and decatur where cho used to
live to tell us what neighbors are
saying joe
according to authorities cho was
originally from china but has lived here
in the united states for several years
one of his most recent addresses was
here at this apartment complex in las
vegas we did speak to one man who used
to be his neighbor he described him as
nice but says he was concerned from time
to time
honestly i would like to ask him like
what's going on with him you know a man
who once lived in this las vegas
apartment is accused of a mass shooting
at a southern california church he was
kind of mad you know before he
disappeared and left disappeared on
february i was being evicted balmore
orianna says he knew david chow for five
years he says he moved after chow's
ex-wife sold the building he described
him as friendly and would even bring his
family gifts he also brought his red
envelopes on chinese new year's
authorities are investigating the
shooting of the taiwanese group as a
hate crime after evidence was found in
his car the same car orianna has seen
here it is believed the suspect involved
was upset about political tensions
between china
and taiwan despite describing him as
friendly orianna did have concerns from
time to time he says a gun was
accidentally fired and went through a
wall nearly hitting a bed last year he
also says there were a few times chow
was verbally abusive with his wife i
told him once you better calm down
don't talk to your wife like that he
didn't after
you know because i wasn't right ariana
says chow did work as a security officer
at the sands convention center in the
past chao's ex-wife told him she was
moving to taiwan last year after being
diagnosed with cancer as for why chao
chose that church it is unclear never
i know he never went to church
i asked ariano if there were any
mentions of dislike or hatred for the
country of taiwan he says no and this
comes as a surprise to him because he
said that cho actually mentioned going
to taiwan a few times in the past
reporting live in spring valley joe
mohler live local now